how're you guys doing
so one other thing first let me start by
saying I really enjoyed the first
episode cannot wait to see where it goes
one of the things about the show is that
some some shows like this everyone
starts together and then they break up
and then it's about how do they come
back together but this one you guys are
all separated and it's an interesting
way to start the show can you sort of
talk about that aspect yeah women
they've been separated for about 17
years so this this is the first event as
you know important enough for them to
all come back together so it's quite
interesting you know for the first
episode there's a lot of awkward
behavior between the family because they
they haven't been around each other for
instance Luther and Allison who had this
kind of connection when they were kids
this is the first time they've seen each
other gonna learn a lot about each other
so and it's the same for all of us you
know we all have these dynamics like
Diego and Luther probably left on bad
terms and stuff and you know with with
Vanya we all saw that she's written this
book about it so we all have our own
opinions about her so yeah it's a real
interesting way you're going to delve
into this world of this family and and
where the dynamic is at mm-hmm well one
of the other things is that this thing
it starts with a ton of mystery and all
as the episode ended I'm like where is
it's gonna go so talk a little bit about
that aspect of the of the season is it
you know that the mystery goes yeah and
I really one thing I really love about
the show is how patient it is you know
and how it reveals information yeah but
yes it gets crazy and crazier and it
lasts and I think that was steve
blackman our showrunner was very very
strategic about how how all of our
stories unwind separately as our
characters but also like as the family
and how we deal with villains and how we
deal with any any sort of like bumps in
the road that we hit and
I'm kind of letting it unfold in a
timely manner that kind of keeps keeps
you wanting to hit next episode as fast
as you possibly can and also but in a
way that makes sense and and nothing
nothing nothing is nothing is soft too
quickly and nothing and nothing is
wasted I feel like it was it's all very
deliberate in the time that it takes to
slowly unwind because it's also in this
kind of adding on to his his the first
question it's we're all coming to this
show our characters and the moment that
you find us in in in a slower pace and
we're all kind of navigating each other
in the same way that we kind of want
then it feels like you want the audience
to navigate the show as well it's like
we're all kind of riding the wave
together no one's in front of anybody
I just spoke to Gerard and he said that
he gave Netflix an arc of where it's all
gonna go including where the comics that
haven't come out yet are going how much
do you know about the full arc of the
show and how much is it sort of not
really very little rate yeah I'd say
almost little Sabaton yeah in terms of
the information from the comics we are
like every member of the public we're
seeing how the comments evolve and we're
just reading them as they come out so
we'll be in the dark like the rest of
them yeah because you know there are
things that are important that are
needed in a TV show that like aren't in
in the novels and vice versa so I think
the finding the the happy medium of of
where to where to elaborate and then
where to leave it for for the page I
think that was also part of Steve's
genius is you know elaborating on the
storylines that that are really good for
television and fun to watch and then and
then kind of leaving leaving other
things for later and or kind of like oh
that's a great part of that character a
great aspect of that of that you know
whatever it is but I think this other
part is better or could is gonna be more
attractive for audiences I have to go I
definitely wanted to ask you about
Dancing but I will save for the next
time
you